speaking of complete nonsense The View
actually had to cut a portion of Anna
Navarro's insane diatribe we're about to
show you because she was using some foul
language
I'm you know I live in Florida
I have been spitting mad about the
culture wars that Ron DeSantis has been
creating so when he says that he has
nothing to do with it
a bunch of blackies and minions to put
that legislation into effect he has
created the environment that has led to
this how dare you shame on you people in
Florida how dare you try to whitewash
slavery and to the commissioner of
Education in Florida many Diaz a
cuban-american that is like saying that
there's a redeeming quality to Cuban
political prisoners under Castro when
you don't have freedom you don't have
anything and for this man Rhonda Sanders
was apparently his only skill that he
has acquired is lying and creating
culture wars that he thinks are going to
make him precedent they're not buddy
that's why you're 30 points down Anna I
beg you to leave this horrific racist
hellhole known as Florida please leave
don't put yourself through this it's
making you very very angry again guys
we're going to get to the facts in just
a moment but one more from The View
because after Whoopi lied about there
being no black scholar is on the thing
Alyssa Farah she's the pet Republican
they pay her about a million bucks a
year to Pat her on the head and pretend
she's a republican so she can always go
after Republicans she actually
acknowledged that yeah well there were
some black Scholars who wrote the
curriculum
I reached out to the Santa says I reach
out to the Santos team this weekend
honestly in hopes that there was some
decent explanation here and basically
what I got from them was well there were
some black Educators and Scholars who
contributed to this and it's been on the
books for over a decade a lot of things
have been on the books for over a decade
that shouldn't be and they're bad and
they're terrible my friend will Hurd I
think said it better than I could have
which was it was literally the most
dehumanizing institution subjugated
people as property because they lacked
any basic rights and freedoms this is
Ron DeSantis doing what I wanted to
think there was better to him but I
wonder I'm realizing there's not okay so
there she is she's not doing it to
debunk whoopee but she's going on their
train their train of Lies
[Music]